welcome back to cbs this morning a
michigan judge who has been criticized
for placing a 15-year-old black girl in
juvenile facility
after she failed to do her homework says
she cannot be released early
the case has prompted demonstrations and
allegations of racism in this case
the girl is being called grace to
protect her identity
she has been in detention and treatment
for more than two months now
for breaking her probation for not doing
the online work
adriana diaz talked to grace's attorneys
this was not an easy decision to make on
monday
a judge denied grace's request for an
early release from a juvenile
residential center
calling her a danger to her mother grace
was placed in detention in may
after violating her probation by failing
to complete online school work
her probation stemmed from a physical
altercation with her mother last fall
and for stealing a student's property
how many times does she get to jump her
mom
before you think that she's a threat of
harm to her mom how many times
the defense pointed out that many
students struggle with virtual learning
especially those like grace who has adhd
and is on a special education plan the
struggle
of a student experiencing disabilities
in time of colvid
it was recognized by the school syma
khalil and jonathan biernat represent
grace
they told oakland county judge mary
ellen brennan that the teen
should be home with her mother grace's
case worker says she's doing
well in the program that she's in right
now why not let her complete that
program
the services she can get at home are far
superior
than the ones provided at by oakland
county
judge brennan said grace's mother
repeatedly called a caseworker for help
there was no point where my client or
the mother
was saying yeah take my kid away from me
and throw her in detention
in the courtroom grace pleaded her case
i believe that this challenge has
specifically brought my mother and i
finally back together you're exactly
where you're supposed to be
you're blooming there but there's more
work to be done
after the hearing grace cried and
embraced her mother
jason smith a director with the michigan
center for youth justice
says grace needs support not punishment
it's frustrating that
instead of trying to figure out a way
that she can get
additional support the first step that
the judge took was to
incarcerate her now
the court issued a statement defending
the judge's decision saying in part
quote
these decisions do not reflect one event
or one bit of information
but rather an extensive review of a
juvenile's case file
now prosecutors have until friday to
respond to a motion from grace's lawyers
to reconsider
if she has to complete the program that
she's in she'll have to remain at the
juvenile facility
for roughly three and a half more months
tony for a long time in a teenager's
life we wish the best of grace we hope
this turns out well adriana thank you
very much